This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Harry’s.
Have you ever been asleep and been jolted
awake by a SUPER loud sound?
Science says that sound only exists in your
head!! *mind blown* Oh,wait... actually that
might be considered insensitive.
Exploding head syndrome sounds like someone
is going to have a lot of cleanup to do, but
it's not about heads that REALLY explode,
but rather a sleep disorder.
Have you ever been asleep or drifting off,
and been suddenly JOLTED AWAKE by a super
loud sound?!
THAT'S exploding head syndrome.
The sound has been associated with a gunshot,
explosion, a thunderclap, or a cymbal clash;
and though it seems real, it's all in the
mind of the person experiencing it.
I've never heard of this, but I've TOTALLY
experienced it; so obviously I have to know
more.
Exploding head syndrome (EHS) was first described
in the 1870s in Virginia Medical Monthly as
a "sense of a pistol shot or a blow on the
head."
It was largely ignored, until 1988 when the
Lancet published a paper that gave it a name[1].
Today, the American Sleep Association (ASA)
characterises EHS as a painless loud sound
sometimes accompanied by a flash of light
followed by anxiety, increased heart rate
and shortness of breath[2].
It can interfere with normal sleep patterns,
which has any number of other effects -- search
DNews; videos for sleep.
There are a lot.
In March, the Washington State University
researchers announced the findings of their
study of 211 undergraduates and found about
one in five students had experienced EHS[3];
though it'a ms most common in people over
50; and SLIGHTLY more common in women[4],[5].
Other studies have found the prevalence closer
to 1 in 8[6].
EHS isn't a minor disorder.
People are jolted awake, and with a huge amount
anxiety, believing someone is breaking in
or a bomb went off a simply cannot determine
what has happened!
It's so disturbing to some people that the've
contrived a conspiracy theory involving electronic
microwave burst harassment by the gub-ment[7].
[a]
In the early 90s, scientists hooked people
up to electroencephalographs, electrooculographs
and submental electromyograms EEGs or similar
devices to watch activity in the brain, and
they didn't find any evidence of problem.
But they did note brain patterns tipped toward
alertness just before the onset of an "attack"
and then everything returned to normal with
no lasting effects[8].
Scientists have tested its connection to headaches
and neurological disorders like epilepsy,
and have yet been unable to determine a cause,
or a good test for it.
But they have a hypothesis for why it happens.
When the brain settles in for sleep the brainstem
reticular formation begins to take over from
the major control neurons.
The BRF controls heartbeat, breathing, eye
movement, and sensorimotor reflex and control[9].[b]
Scientists think in people with exploding
head syndrome, the neurons don't shut down
correctly and instead they fire all at once
for some reason causing this fantastic sound.
Evidence seems to point to the brainstem reticular
formation, because it also controls sleep
paralysis, which is occasionally associated
with EHS.
A German study of EHS found that while there
is no cure, the best treatment is to reassure
people that YES it's in your head.
It's completely fine.
And it's not going to harm you.
But it's weird and strange and research is
ongoing, and needed.
We couldn't have made this episode of DNews
without support from Harry's.
If you need a razor to shave with.
Try Harry's!
Harry's was started by a couple guys who liked
shaving so much that bought a razor factory
to make their own.
They're cheap, they show up at your door,
and they're sharp both in look and… well,
sharpness.
Not only did they make it so you don't have
to pay a ton for blades, they made them easier
to get!
If you want to try Harry's and support the
show go to Harrys.com and use the promo code
DNews to save $5 off your first order.
Have you experienced Exploding Head Syndrome?
Tell us!